asylum seekers will be sent from the uk
to rwanda in a news anyone entering the
uk illegally may now be relocated to
rwanda the scheme has been widely
criticised
but why is it controversial and what
the government wants to send people who
arrive illegally in the uk to rwanda it
will pay this small east african nation
120 million up front as an initial
payment and there's ultimately no limit
to the number of people who could be
sent in 120 million pounds is the
estimated cost of this particular
arrangement that's a figure which will
alter depending on how whether the
scheme works home officers said there'll
be a cost per relocated person but
exactly how much
we don't know
so who does it apply to well anyone the
home office thinks has taken a dangerous
unnecessary or illegal journey to the uk
apart from lone migrant children who are
exempt for rwanda it's in their national
financial and reputational interest to
take in these people it'll give their
economy a boost and a bigger standing on
the world stage
people who aren't eligible for asylum in
the uk will board chartered flights to
rwanda they'll enter the asylum system
here and stay in accommodation like this
we have a
twin room meaning that each room has a
capacitor accommodating to a person the
signs are in english and arabic
there's a prayer room
two computer centers and a gift shop we
have some
different things like
clothes and cigarettes as as you know
they like a cigarette yes
miranda's government has said it will
offer asylum seekers human capital
investments like language lessons and
skills and once they are given refugee
status they will be able to look for a
job
we are giving them the chance to make
new lives in our country as full members
of our communities
[Music]
the government has been under pressure
to find a solution to the number of
people arriving in the uk
in the first five months of 2022 alone 8
000 people arrived in the uk after
crossing the channel
in the same period last year it was
three thousand one hundred and twelve
and the year before it was one thousand
three hundred and forty
the government hopes the scheme will
deter others wanting to make the journey
these vile people smokers are abusing
the bomber
and turning the channel into a watery
graveyard the idea behind the scheme
isn't new denmark israel and australia
have implemented similar schemes in
recent years and as of june 2022 the us
is set to send migrants to spain
i'm not sure if it's going to work i
think it's a good idea that we're we're
helping them out i think you need to do
something to deter people a from risking
their lives as they're coming across the
water and also to display people that
where they should be claiming asylum is
in france
i think we've got enough problems with
our own housing
and situations like that over it
a poll on the day the scheme was
announced found nearly a third of people
strongly opposed to it
and prince charles apparently called it
appalling in a private conversation
[Music]
the asylum process is quite frankly it's
been a mess for decades successive
governments have failed to really
introduce
a fair transparent asylum process that's
the root of the problem and rather than
trying to resolve that the home office
and the government deciding to actually
shift the problem away
rice group said the policy puts people's
lives at risk and is an unlawful way to
treat asylum seekers before deportation
and once sent to rwanda
rwanda has said they have experience
hosting refugees so people need to give
the partnership a chance it has to start
at some point so this is a beginning
[Music]